on parle d'immigration n'impressionnera
public donc a dit qu'il était favorable
à ce que le parlement l'assemblée
nationale pour être précis se focalise
chaque année sur le sujet peut-être pour
mettre des quotas d'immigration
est ce une bonne idée ou pas écouter
l'avis de rang berger c'est la porte
parole de la république en marche pour
elle les quotas oui mais pas pour tous
les immigrés avec nos bons joueurs
non il y aura jamais de potasse sur le
droit d'asile ce serait inacceptable
bon par contre moi je pense qu'il faut
pas avoir peur des mots on a demandé et
on souhaite avoir un débat chaque année
en septembre exactement sur la question
des obligations si on commence avant
même le débat de à se dire attention il
faut pas qu'on utilise tellement parce
qu'on aurait peur de son utilisation
notamment le mot quota voit dans ces cas
ce débat n'a rien donc on peut avoir le
droit d'ouvrir le débat en disant est ce
que ce septembre à bout peut-être que
sur l'immigration économique des quotas
pourraient être efficaces et pour vous
aider à vous faire votre point de vue je
vous propose d'écouter de réactions
critiques sur ce projet une critique
très à gauche et une critique très à
droite on commence avec le côté gauche
eric coquerel député la france insoumise
de seine-saint-denis pour lui ce n'est
vraiment pas une bonne idée
j'ai pas trop en quoi ça consiste un
quota quoi professionnel par pays de
départ après l'arrivée massive en europe
de réfugiés notamment due aux guerres
sur lesquels nous avons des
responsabilités
aujourd'hui il y a moins d'immigrés qui
arrivait et de réfugiés qui arrivent en
europe donc arrêtons de laisser penser
que ce serait le problème
arrêtons de deux commandes est de faire
en sorte que les laisser fantasme
alimente le débat politique et enfin
voici un dernier point de vue politique
celui de sébastien chenu lui et député
d'une heure mais porte parole du
rassemblement national il était ce matin
sur lci
et pour lui les quotas c'est tout
simplement pas possible
d'abord schengen nous l'interdît donc le
débat est limité schengen nous interdit
tant qu'on ne sort pas de schengen on ne
peut pas avoir de place chez nous en
france 2
de prendre une partie cessa de
l'immigration oui absolument et le pacte
de marrakech avec de jeu vous dire on
verra après sur le fait de
l'impossibilité éventuelle mais sur le
principe est ce que c'est une bonne idée
les quotas d'immigration ça existe dans
d'autres pays oui à d'autres pays où ça
existe
alors évidemment il ya les réfugiés
guerre qui sont un cas très particulier
il s'agit là d'un droit d'asile tout à
fait dire humanitaires élémentaires et
puis vous avez deux passions général
l'immigration économique qui fait que
des gens sont attirés de façon assez
rationnel par pourrait dire une
prospérité qui veulent trouver dans dans
d'autres pays c'est assez compréhensible
mais on ne peut aussi comprendre qu'il y
à une logique à imposer alors c'est quoi
les quotas monsieur cochrane poser des
questions ce sont des quotas de
compétences enfin en tout cas c'est
comme ça que je comprends l'idée c'est
que nous devons réfléchir et le canada
le fait depuis longtemps à ce que aux
compétences dont nous avons besoin et à
prendre des gens qui peuvent répondre à
ses compétences ce qui est une façon de
nous servir nous en tant que pays notre
prospérité mais ce qui est une façon
aussi de servir ces gens qu'ils
trouveront un équilibre économique et
une insertion économique ce qui est
quand même la première partie pour une
insertion sociale réussie il faut avoir
un travail
mathilde a gagné c'est une bonne idée ce
cette idée de dire chaque année par
voilà les emplois dans la france a
besoin donc faisons venir les gens qui
répondent à ces critères
alors je sais pas si c'est comme ça que
l'idée du quota des quotas prospère dans
notre débat public
d'abord c'est une idée qui revient tous
les ans ou moins grands guen le débat
avait déjà eu lieu dans les années 2000
avec une des propositions portées par
nicolas sarkozy et françois fillon
l'avait mis dans son programme
présidentiel en 2017
alors là si on veut être un peu plus
clair et sortir des slogans puisque mon
sentiment c'est que la question de
l'immigration
la prison m'a kron avait essayé de
l'injecter dans le débat d'un grand
débat national et on voit aujourd'hui
que de nouveaux ils essaient de mettre
ça au devant de l'actualité
la question des quotas l'existant dans
certains pays mais elle n'existe que
pour l'équipe que pour évidemment
l'immigration économique puisqu'elle ne
peut pas exister pour vous l'avez très
bien dit pour droit d'asile
elle ne peut pas exister sur le
regroupement familial en raison
notamment des éditions du conseil
constitutionnel est ou de nos
engagements internationaux donc ça ne
peut être que pour les gens qui veulent
venir en france pour travailler
cette immigration là aujourd'hui elles
représentent moins de 10% d'immigration
française
et quand il ya des quotas qui sont
organisées dans les pays vous avez parlé
du canada c'est parce que c'est des pays
qui décident de d'augmenter de manière
puissante et bien leur force de travail
en ayant recours à l'immigration
permettez moi de penser mais au sauf si
c'est une annonce du président de la
république que ce n'est pas comme ça que
christophe castaner annonce qu'il veut
poser la question des quotas on voit
bien qu'ils essaient de poser la
question des quotas pour indiquer qu'il
veut réduire l'immigration qui est pour
moi un faux débat aujourd'hui parce que
c'est pas la question première donc en
fait le seul moyen de réguler
l'immigration aujourd'hui c'est de
revoir le système de dublin c'est à dire
au niveau européen la question des
quotas c'est un slogan ça n'a pas
souvent été évoquée
ça jamais été mises en oeuvre et
aujourd'hui je ne vois pas comment on
pourrait le faire en france si ce n'est
à utiliser le quota comme et bien un
moyen d'augmenter massivement
l'immigration dans le pays l'augmenter
oui parce que vous voyez bien
qu'aujourd'hui la question qui est posée
est comment font aujourd'hui les gens
qui veulent avoir
2 qui veulent venir en france au nom de
l'immigration économique ils le font pas
comme ça par départ des quotas vous êtes
obligés d'avoir d'abord un contrat de
travail donc les conditions sont partis
comme en difficile c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il n'ya que 10 % de
l'immigration française qui est dit à
l'immigration économique
donc si vous vous dites que vous voulez
des quotas ça ne peut pas être pour les
réduire parce que aujourd'hui sont déjà
sait gérer le nombre est relativement
faible donc ça ne peut être jeu
reprenait la balle au bond de mon
précédent interlocuteurs que si vous
êtes dans une démarche qui est celle de
grands pays européens qui ont ou non
européens en l'occurrence le canada qui
est bien ont des recours régulier et
massif est bien à de la force de travail
extérieur à leur pays il y avait avec
les est ce qu'on est en train de dire
c'est que finalement on ne peut pas
réduire l'immigration ce qui est ce qui
est certain c'est que là christophe
castaner montre qu'il a la volonté de le
faire
ou en tout cas qu'il a acté le fait que
les français jugé que c'était un
problème et qu'il fallait faire quelque
chose qui est déjà énorme parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'on a eu du déni
du côté de la république en marché et de
la gauche aussi de façon très générale
maintenant dans les faits il paraît
assez clair que le quota apparaît comme
un mot comme un mot gadget
parce que ça ne touche pas le droit
d'asile on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui
le droit d'asile ne soyons pas naïfs il
est quand même largement des voiliers ce
ne sont pas que des gens en provenance
de pays où ils sont vraiment
véritablement en danger qui utilisent
cette voie là donc là on ne salit
touchera pas on peut dire aussi que dans
la mesure où on n'a pas retrouvé la
maîtrise de nos frontières on voit pas
bien comment on garderait ses quotas de
et ce qui empêcherait les individus les
personnes concernées de passer d'un pays
à l'autre
donc on a le sentiment que sans doute ce
peut-on retrouver la maîtrise de
l'immigration notamment par la la la la
la la reprise de la souveraineté de
notre pays mais ce quota est un est un
beau gadget qui est plus là sans doute
pour pour faire plaisir et puis pour
montrer un électorat populiste qu'on a
pris acte de ces de ses inquiétudes et
vous faisiez allusion comme maxime
dégâts liés à cette interview de
christophe castaner 1re au jdd d'hier
dans lequel elle disait que la question
des quotas pouvait être posée dans le
cadre du débat
pas pour les demandeurs d'asile mais
pour d'autres modes d du d'immigration
légale jeunes inquiète une guerre votre
point de vue mon point de vue c'est que
c'est une décision politique
emmanuel macron montre c'est un signe
qui s'intéressent à l'immigration parce
qu'il est conscient que ce sujet de
l'immigration qui restait finalement
assez en retrait pendant les dernières
élections européennes va être un sujet
très forts de l'élection présidentielle
de 2000 22 doc il semblait jusque là
très en retrait sur ces questions et
donner l'impression de s'y intéresser
peu et là il prend et prend la
problématique à bras le corps alors il
la prend avec la question des quotas
c'est vrai ce que vous disiez madame en
ce qui concerne l'immigration illégale
qui est l'une des immigrations qui pose
problème
les quotas la résoudrons pas après pour
ce qui concerne l'immigration économique
est-ce que ça ça permettra peut-être de
mieux réguler cette adéquation entre les
besoins qu'à notre économie et les
profils des immigrants économiques
appelés à rentrer dans ce pays
marche assez bien au canada pourquoi
est-ce que ça fonctionnerait pas en
france après tout cela dit nicolas
sarkozy qui était au départ très
favorable aux quotas avait demandé en
2009 je crois pierre mazeaud un rapport
sur la question et pierre mazet on avait
conclu que ça serait totalement inutile
donc on était revenu sur cette idée des
quotas en pensant que ce serait
inopérant mais l'intérêt pour emmanuel
macron c'est quand même aussi d'associer
le parlement au débat de tout mettre sur
la table et que chaque année il est
finalement un débat parlementaire sur la
question de l'immigration donc que
l'ensemble de la classe politique prenne
ses responsabilités sur cette question
il fasse publiquement les internautes du
figaro en tout cas sont assez
massivement favorables à une telle
mesure c'est la question du figaro.fr et
83% se montre donc en faveur de
l'instauration de quotas établis chaque
année au terme d'un débat parlementaire
olivier babeau il ya quand même un
risque si on se saisit de ce sujet mais
pour finalement faire le contrat le
constat pendant que vous faites tous
autour de cette table c'est qu'on ne
peut pas faire grand chose
ça risque d'être contre-productive c'est
à dire que leur assemblée nationale va
dire vous voyez on dit qu'on agit contre
l'immigration mais la vérité c'est qu'il
ya toujours autant de gens qui rentrent
c'est politiquement un jeu délicat parce
qu'effectivement vous ouvrez ce sujet en
essayant pourrait dire de ramener à vous
ou peut-être on d'empêcher le départ de
certains électeurs
nous ne faisons pas l'autruche on voit
très bien que c'est ce problème là qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui le rassemblement
national est devenu de fait le premier
parti de france et donc ils veulent
traiter cette question
le risque en quelque sorte c'est que si
on n'apporte pas de réponse
satisfaisante du point de vue du grand
public on apporte en quelque sorte de
l'eau au moulin
moi je trouve qu'on pourrait traiter
d'une façon pourrait dire inverse
intéressante qui serait de dire mais on
doit être attractif pour les cerveaux le
drame aujourd'hui c'est qu'on n'est plus
capable de faire venir à nous alors que
pourtant on a tellement d'atouts en
france on a tellement de raisons d'en
monter brigands de faire venir les gens
on n'arrive plus à faire venir
nono les plus grands chercheurs les plus
grand sérieux tous les gens ici sont les
mais exactement le vrai drame c'est
justement qu'on est sorti des cerveaux
cette fuite des cerveaux terrible c'est
cette question qu'il faudrait poser en
priorité comment rétablir l'attractivité
de la france
il ya par exemple évidemment les
salaires des chercheurs c'est une des
questions la question des salaires des
chercheurs là où je vous rejoins ce
qu'il faut avoir une vraie stratégie sur
l'attractivité de la france c'est notre
capacité effectivement à trouver une
place qu'on a pu jouer d'ailleurs il ya
quelques décennies
dans la scène mondiale en faisant venir
des talents et en formant des gens or
c'est quand même paradoxal on est formé
par fort bien et ils s'en vont oui et
puis on a
nous faisons pas échappé que toute une
série de décisions notamment pour
augmenter les frais d'inscription des
étudiants pour réduire ce qui était
quand même quelque chose en terme de
rayonnement international assez puissant
qui était le réseau des écoles
françaises pour les réduire de manière
drastique au new dans de nombreux dans
de nombreux pays
donc en réalité on a du mal aujourd'hui
à comprendre en quoi le fait de poser la
question des quotas s'inscrit dans une
stratégie qui une stratégie qui
malheureusement n'existe pas et en plus
à prendre par les quotas vous l'avez
tous très bien souligné avec des
arguments qui nous sont des uns aux
autres évidemment différent on voit bien
que sanaa ça n'a pas grand sens donc au
final on en revient toujours à la même
chose c'est pourquoi est ce qu'il y ait
une intervention du ministre de
l'intérieur sur ce sujet là et je pense
que il ya la volonté évidemment de
remettre à la jma un sujet qui que je ne
me leurre pas mais qui en réalité
n'était pas dans la préoccupante dans
les préoccupations prioritaires des
français ces derniers mois est apte à
volonté c'était dans les préoccupations
prioritaires des français dans les
sondages avant les européennes et après
les européennes c'est à dire dans un
précèdent avait répondu la semaine
passée par là mais il y avait le pouvoir
d'achat et l'immigration
et c'était en fonction des semaines
s'ils n'avaient en rien les français ne
sont pas déterminées par rapport à
l'immigration effectivement lors des
européennes contrairement à ce que
semblent dire les sondages quelques
semaines avant peut-être gabriel cluzel
que le gouvernement sort ce sujet du
chapeau pour rassurer entre guillemets
l'électorat de droite et mieux faire
passer à la pma pour les couples de
lesbiennes et les femmes seules et met
en effet c'est précisément là la
réflexion que je me suis fait c'est
qu'on a dit aux dernières européennes
finalement
l'un public en marche avait réussi à
rallier une partie de l'électorat non
négligeable de droite
donc c'est une façon c'est un mot totem
qui lui envoie des signaux du reste on
voit les sondages c'est vrai que les
gens sont majoritairement favorables
peut-être pas parce qu'ils pensent que
le quota et est efficace mais parce
qu'ils se disent à au moins on met le
sujet sur la table peut-être avec des
outils dérisoire peut-être avec des
outils qui ne fonctionneront pas mais on
met le sujet sur la table et je crois
que c'est vraiment pour moi selon moi la
signification du sondage que vous citiez
dire pardonnez moi que le que ce n'est
pas la préoccupation majeure des
français
je pense que c'est s'est creusé un petit
peu plus le trou de 2 pour mettre la
tête de l'autruche si vous me permettez
cette expression on sait bien que c'est
une inquiétude qui actuellement est en
france mais dans toute l'europe et tout
ce qui finalement réussissent à
s'imposer dans les gouvernements parce
qu'on a dit qu emmanuel macron avait
avait moins perdu donc il avait plus
gagné ainsi je vois là et bien malgré
tout il sort pas vainqueur de ces
élections et et je crois que ceux qui
qui refuse d'évoquer ce sujet là sont
perdants à tous les coups moi j'irais
même jusqu'à dire que parmi les
électeurs de la république en marche il
y en a beaucoup qui ont aussi cette
inquiétude là qui ont aussi cette
interrogation là mais même s'ils n'en
font pas forcément et a tout d'abord
mais dans le cadre des découvertes des
conversations privées j'ai noté que ça
ressorte est extrêmement fréquent
fréquemment et de façon qui d'une façon
qui transcende tous les partis
politiques j'entends ce que vous dites
est ce que j'ai l'air d'être d'ailleurs
d'une certaine manière si emmanuel
macron et le ministre de l'intérieur
parle de quotas comme vous le dites ça
vient prolonger la politique qu'il mène
depuis maintenant deux ans sur ces
sujets là il ya quand même des lois et
le projet de loi colons qui pour plein
de raisons qu'on évoquera pas ici mais
était largement contestable et donc on
va dire qu'il fait preuve de cohérence
là on va dire un discours entre nous
mais plutôt de droite sur ces sujets là
vous m'autoriserai quand même à
considérer que c'était pas les propos et
le positionnement initial des manuels
macron lorsque il fait sa campagne
présidentielle que il avait à l'époque
un discours qui était beaucoup plus
accueillant ça ne veut pas dire qu'on
ait jamais vous vous sentez travail le
socialisme
alors je me sens mâcon comme non non je
ne crois pas à ce que vous espériez nuit
je voulais parce que je les avais voté
mais je n'en espérais pas grand chose si
je suis toujours socialiste j'avais
peut-être vu peut-être avant d'autres le
fait qu'il fallait se méfier ce que je
note juste c'est qu'on est dans une
grande période de clarification
l'électorat d'ailleurs s'y est pas
trompé puisque aujourd'hui c'est un
électorat de droite qui s'est substitué
un électorat de gauche
et quant aux politiques menées ces des
politiques de droite et donc d'une
certaine manière il prolonge et bien le
changement de 4 qu'il a eue depuis le
jour où il a été il a été lui fallait
romano monte encore à la politique par
eva j'espérais quand on entre là très
bien pma et l'immigration moi je pense
que sur ces deux sujets emmanuel macron
a quand même beaucoup akram de sa
majorité parce que je pense que aussi
bien sûr la pma pour toutes les femmes
pour les femmes homosexuelles que sur
l'immigration est d'ailleurs des
dissensions au sein du groupe la
république en marche
ce sont deux sujets de société sur
lesquels vous avez de réelles ligne de
fracture au sein même du groupe donc il
ya une prise de risque politique de sa
part en se confrontant à ces deux
thématiques oman moment je vous propose
de laisser le dernier mot sur ce sujet à
nos internautes est l un des plus
fidèles d'entre le désormais célèbre
babineau qui nous dit c'est difficile
d'instaurer des quotas et en même temps
de rester au sein de l'union européenne
le modèle canadien n'est pas comparable
effectivement c'est notamment avec cause
des de tous les accords signés avec nos
partenaires de l'union européenne et
puis il ajoute qu'il n'ya pas de volonté
politique de réduction de l'immigration
du gouvernement macron les quotas c'est
un peu la carte joker